in our series the new normal we look at
how the pandemic is dramatically
changing our everyday lives and this
morning we're focusing
on some of the shortages many of them
unexpected that have emerged as
americans spend more time at home
and more time turning to diy projects
vlad gta has been tracking some of the
items
that have become hard to find welcome to
maryland
armelle posey is driving back to
maryland from pennsylvania
two-hour journey with his brother isent
in search of lumber
that's right lumber it's kind of
frustrating having to drive
around not being able to find what you
need frustrating because of this
a fencing that's still unfinished at
home depot
you can see most of the shelf are empty
and lumber nowhere to be found to build
a fence or deck it technically take me
two or three days
if i have everything that i need so far
i'm about two weeks
and i still not done yet all over the
country the need for lumber is on the
rise
as restaurants are turning sidewalks and
parking spots into
outdoor dining havens the wood is not
the only item flying off the shelves
i'm trying to get a new bike and they
told me i'd have to pre-order it would
be at least september
high demand but short supply as
customers lined up at this bike shop in
dallas even before
store hours certainly we have seen
demand spike in a way that i've never
witnessed in my 18 years here
from pools of all sizes i have a
two-year-old at home
just trying to survive to coins aluminum
cans
and even puppies there has been a
nationwide shortage of some very
unexpected items the coronavirus
certainly has played a role
but i think customer behavior has also
played a role
sunil chopra is a professor at
northwestern university
what covet 19 has done is provide a
shock to the system
that these manufacturers did not
anticipate absolutely
it's provided a demand shock to the
systems people who otherwise would not
have bought those puzzles
are buying puzzles now same thing with
exercise equipment so you have a sudden
surge in demand
which most suppliers are just not
prepared for
a recent survey found that 97 percent of
organizations reported a disruption due
to the pandemic
fewer supplies combined with a boom in
demand
everybody being home they want to build
decks so anything that was in there
is now gone are those projects really
enough
to fundamentally change the supply chain
in the long term no because you know we
are only going to do
so many projects over the long term
but in the short term this does cause
significant disruption
a disruption that armel and his brother
now have to deal with
as they continue their cross-state
pursuit for that perfect backyard
if i had to do this again most likely i
would take my time and put together or
assemble everything that i need
before starting it's kind of defeating
the purpose of having your privacy fence
if
you don't complete the whole thing
i spoke to some restaurant owners over
the weekend where they have built those
extensions with lumber
took them weeks to procure from multiple
suppliers
tony with more and more restaurants
opting for outdoor dining just to
survive this pandemic the demand for
those wooden planks
and that fencing will keep going higher
and higher yeah the demand for the
planks and the fencing will go higher
and higher as well as demand for the
parking places that used to be where the
fencing now is
so you know one shortage leads to
another uh scarce resources
in city living with such his life flat
very interesting piece i was surprised
to see so many shortages particularly
exercise equipment because i'm as lazy
as ever
thank you very much